there's another kind of instinct that
you need to be on the lookout for and
this one is a liar this one is a
saboteur this one is a back biter and
like the devil himself visa shapeshifter
he's gonna disguise himself and make you
think he's got your best interest in
mind but he doesn't this is the instinct
that says you've had enough this is the
instinct that says you've you've given
it your best shot
you can you can stand down you can back
off you can take a knee this is the
instinct that says you can rest now do
not listen to that instinct do not
listen that instinct is a liar and wants
to bring you down that that's the
instinct that's a defense mechanism it
wants to give you an out place to run to
little little place of sympathy then
amnesty a little place of amnesty where
everything is forgiven where all these
these failures can gather together and
comfort and drown their sorrows in lies
and in deception and they tell each
other and they'll tell you you did the
best you could now they'll say the DAK
the deck the deck was stacked against
you and they'll say it's not your fault
and they'll tell you
it's okay to stop it's okay to settle
it's okay to give up and that is the
instinct you need to fight you need to
push back to smash into the ground do
not take the easy way out do not give up
based on instinct if you are forced to
stand down to retreat so that you can
rebuild Andreea tak so be it but make
that decision based on logic not on the
instinct of surrender and defeat and you
need to train that instinct your
instinct
train it to say get up go fight on and
if that is what you become if that
becomes your fundamental reaction to
adversity if that becomes your gut
instinct then you will overcome just
about anything that stands in your path